estas calles ahora Aparentemente
tranquilas fueron el escenario de un fin
de semana lleno de protestas poco
comunes contra el gobierno chino y su
política de Cero covid en unas jornadas
inéditas de desobediencia civil desde
que el presidente chillin asumió el
poder hace más de una década La chispa
que encendió la llama fue el incendio en
el edificio de orum capital de chingyang
donde según los ciudadanos a las
operaciones de rescate se complicaron
por las restricciones contra el covid
versión que las autoridades niegan las
protestas se extendieron rápidamente por
diferentes puntos del país como Shangai
uhana
como todo el mundo sabe en los últimos
años se ha bloqueado nuestra libertad de
expresión y las distintas formas de
expresarnos No pensé en que llegaría el
día en el que saldríamos a la calle para
expresar nuestras demandas
Y es que los chinos llevan tres años
lidiando con las estrictas políticas
anticovid ahora aunque no hay
confinamientos a nivel nacional las
autoridades locales deben imponer
estrictos cierres se detectan positivos
en Kobe 19 pero a pesar de las críticas
nacionales e internacionales el gobierno
chino sostuvo que las protestas Fueron
fomentadas por occidente
creemos que con el liderazgo del partido
comunista chino y el apoyo del pueblo
chino nuestra lucha contra el Kobe 19
tendrá éxito
desde el inicio de las protestas se
registraron imágenes de la represión de
la policía china con un número
indeterminado de detenidos entre ellos
el periodista de la cadena bbc Lawrence
detenido durante varias horas en
Shanghai y supuestamente agredido por la
policía antes de liberarlo una situación
que ha generado preocupación entre la
comunidad internacional con protestas de
solidaridad en países como Reino Unido o
Japón y que ha hecho que los mercados
mundiales se desplomen este raro gesto
de desobediencia por parte del pueblo